Hey, we had we had some insanely long live streams
last week because of the armed insurrection.
And we got a great call on our voicemail
number, which is two one nine two. David P,
just a very nice person saying thanks for the live
streams. Thanks for the long days. Take a listen.
Hi, this message is for Mr. Pakman,
this is Ambrosia. I wanted to
let you know that you did an
outstanding job yesterday, January six,
with your Lifestream. You were staring
for like six or seven hours and.
It's crazy because your commentary
made sense, you didn't wear out.
You stepped up a little bit
and then you came back and
it was better than any mainstream media
news outlet coverage that I saw. I
got most, if not all, of my information from
your live stream. So I just wanted to say
you did an outstanding job. You
did. And my props to you and.
Bottom line from Texas, and we don't
we do not blame Ted Cruz. We don't.
OK, thanks so much, Pakman.
All right. There it is,
a beautiful message. I really do appreciate it.
We had. Yeah. I mean, on the 6th as we watched
what we thought would be a very boring but
long many hours of debate over objections to
counting ballots, we saw the armed insurrection
grow before our very eyes and they were very long
days. I really appreciate hearing from folks who
who appreciated us, us being with you. And it was
a privilege to be with everybody who joined those
streams. And we're going to continue covering.
Unfortunately, I hate to say it, but I believe
that there will be more to cover in the next
week. And of course, we will be with you on
January 20th for the inauguration and swearing in
of President Joseph R. Biden Jr.. So much, much
to come. And of course, the streams are live.
We're typically live on three platforms,
YouTube, which is YouTube, dotcom slash, The
David Pakman Show, Twitch, Twitch, dot
TV slash David Pakman and Facebook,
Facebook dotcom slash David Pakman show.
So I will see you. But before that,
we do have a great bonus show for you today.
Senator Joe Manchin has a different view about
stimulus checks already. It didn't take long,
my friend. So we will you know, the idea of
is Joe Manchin going to be OK with this? It's not
just a meme. It's not just a mere hypothetical. It
immediately has an impact. We'll also talk about
the Biden administration's different approach on
vaccine doses. Really important topic. And we
will also talk about a West Virginia Republican
state lawmaker who has resigned after being
allegedly involved in the riotous storming
of the U.S. Capitol. So we will have all of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
As I will be joined by producer Pat, you can sign
up and get instant access at join Pakman Dotcom.